before we go we have some good vibes and
today they're brought to you by canada's
very own michael buble
yeah in a new segment for global's a
late show with stephen colbert michael
is teaching the world all about canadian
cuisine and food court canadian edition
what's your favorite canadian
dish oh i mean just i mean the first
thing that comes to mind
i love it so good and you can catch more
with michael as we chat one-on-one with
him to celebrate his brand new album
hire love next friday april 15th at 7 30
p.m on global take care everyone see you
next time bye-bye
all right we'll start off with the
obvious maple syrup what is my
relationship with maple syrup well i
think honestly that's private what i do
in my bedroom is up to me just use it
trust me maple syrup toffee there is
nothing more canadian than making maple
syrup and toffee in a bed of snow unless
you're eating ketchup chips a little
poutine and you're making out with
celine
beaver tails versus elephant ears beaver
tails
it sounds sexual but
also delicious
uh i think it's like a canadian
donut or something
no it's like a beaver
uh-huh canadian bacon
versus american bacon
oh this hurts me to say
this does hurt me to say but i'm gonna
choose american bacon i don't like the
canadian bacon i like just a good old
american
bacon you know simple and crispy and
yummy
sorry canada
i'm so sorry
last time alanis morissette ever invites
me over to have breakfast with her
this last one is the easiest of the
bunch a bloody caesar versus the bloody
mary
let me tell you my american friends if
you've never done yourself the favor of
having a caesar which is a mix of vodka
worcestershire
clamato i know it sounds weird clam
juice with tomato it sounds weird it's
the best in the world and tabasco do
yourself a favor go to canada drink a
bunch of caesars get yourself all sexy
get a bunch of maple syrup if you know
what i mean
and slap those beaver tails around